looks like it's 10 30 so let's get
started
um so welcome to
the first session of the third day of
itcs
and today we we're starting with a
really nice uh set of talks about
algebraic complexity
so
i'm gonna give just a quick introduction
and then we'll have nine minute talks
about about the five different papers in
this session
um and these are five papers which
really make
new insights into
like ways of thinking about five
different fundamental problems in
algebraic complexity so i think it'll
the session will give us really a nice
tour of of five different important
problems in this area
um so let me really quickly just tell
you what the five papers are about
um so the first one studies the
polynomial identity testing problem this
is a problem where you're given an
arithmetic circuit and your goal is to
figure out whether or not it always
outputs zero no matter what you give it
as input
and there's a nice randomized algorithm
for this problem you might be familiar
with where you can just plug in some
random inputs
but it's a major challenge to find an
efficient deterministic algorithm for
this problem
so
one
common approach to the problem to
designing a deterministic algorithm is
to design something called a hitting set
generator where
roughly an andrew will tell us more
about this what you want to do is
find a nice simple set of polynomials
that you can compose with your circuit
that your promise won't make your
circuit like cancel out by accident
and in this paper they show that by
looking for rational functions as
fitting set generators instead of
polynomials um it can lead into some
really nice insights into the structure
of these hitting set generators and
really recent constructions of them
so that's the first paper
uh the second one studies arithmetic
circuits for problems like the
determinant and the permanent which are
fundamental and difficult to tackle
problems at the center of the vp versus
vnp problem which is like the algebraic
analog of the p versus np problem
um so since these two problems have a
lot of symmetries uh it's that natural
to ask what happens if you restrict your
arithmetic circuits to also be invariant
under under these kinds of symmetries
and
the paper studies what kinds of
constructions and especially what kinds
of lower bounds are possible when you
restrict your circuits in this way
they're a lot stronger than what you can
improve uh without such symmetry
restrictions
okay the third paper studies another
important problem the symbolic
determinant identity testing problem so
in this problem you're given as input
a set of a lot of low rank matrices and
your goal is to figure out whether it's
possible to like rescale and add these
low rank matrices together to get a full
rank matrix or whether no matter how you
do that you always still get a
low rank matrix
so the paper studies
the setting where these input matrices
come from a special case where they come
from a lee algebra and they show that
so on one hand a lot of the properties
that seem to make the problem hard still
come up in this lia algebra setting but
on the other hand they're able to give
an efficient algorithm for solving the
problem in this setting so there's a
cool dichotomy in this special case
the fourth problem studies a learning
problem in algebraic complexity called
the black block box reconstruction
problem
um so in this problem you get black
block
access to a polynomial and your promise
this polynomial has a relatively simple
circuit
so you can just keep picking inputs and
get back the outputs of the polynomial
on those inputs and your goal is to
construct a simple circuit that computes
that polynomial
um so this paper really pushes the depth
like the frontiers of what we can do
by giving
more efficient algorithms for uh i guess
the titular depth three circuits with
top fin and two for this problem
um and then last but not least the final
paper studies another really natural
variant on arithmetic circuits called
monotone arithmetic circuits
where you're computing a monotone
polynomial kind of like you know it
doesn't somehow it doesn't have minus
signs in its definition just like pluses
and times
um and your goal is to also give a
circuit which doesn't take advantage of
minus signs for computing it
um so they're able to give really nice
lower bounds against this model like
they study this so-called spanning tree
polynomial which has very efficient
arithmetic circuits that don't have to
be monotone but they show a strongly
exponential lower bound for circuits
that do have to be monotone for
computing
okay so those are the five problems
we're going to see today and with that
let's get started with the talks
so andrew could you
share your screen yes
i will stop sharing my screen
i apologize in advance i had some issues
joining the meeting at first so i'm i
missed your discussion of what we said
so i apologize if i uh repeat something
but uh
yeah
it's been interesting
okay
are we good to go
yeah
okay
great uh so uh i'm andrew morgan uh this
is a talk on polynomial identity testing
the evaluation of rational functions and
represents joint work with ddr5
so polynomial identity testing is this
problem we are given an arithmetic
formula computing a polynomial p
you have to decide whether or not p is
the zero polynomial
there's a simple randomized algorithm
you just evaluate p at a random point
and it's a major open problem whether
there's an efficient deterministic
algorithm
uh there's white boxes randomization
which is just an arbitrary efficient
deterministic algorithm
there's also black box through
randomization where only evaluations are
allowed basically you're coming up with
pseudo-random inputs to the randomized
algorithm
so both of these have connections with
circuit lower bounds and the boolean
setting
and a particular function that's kind of
morally complete problems for
de-randomizing all of bpp in particular
for black box to your immunization
so we'll focus on that in this talk
and in black box do randomization
polynomial identity testing
you have a generator as kind of the
central object of study
and generators for pit without also
generality have the following form
there's a set of c variables and the
substitution is each x i gets a
polynomial in those seed variables
and what you want is that as long as
your polynomial p is nonzero then this
composition of polynomials should be
non-zero for all p and
some restricted class c
so for black box duranomization what you
do is you design a generator with small
seed and a small degree
and then you test whether this
composition is zero by using random
evaluations of the seed variables
and then because the number of seed
variables is much smaller and as long as
the degrees are bounded
then this is a lot more randomness
efficient in particular you can just
reverse the randomness and get an
efficient deterministic algorithm
so uh that's the basic setup uh blackbox
deranimization of bit
um so we make some progress on this it's
obviously a challenging problem so it's
you know progress is always slow
uh but uh here's what we did
so uh first of all we demonstrate the
utility of doing uh rational function
substitutions rather than just
polynomial substitutions
um so even though polynomial
substitutions are without loss of
generality
um
they uh
even though rational results even though
polynomial substitutions are without
loss of generality
uh rational function substitutions can
be so interesting in particular
the rational function evaluation
generator is a new generator that we
introduce
and turns out to be interesting
so we study it by
different approach where we look at the
vanishing ideal of the generator
and this extends to all generators
so the vanishing idea of a generator g
is just the set of polynomials such that
when you plug in the generator
at
looks like zero polynomial
and the vanishing ideal is important
because for any class c of polynomials
uh g works to de-randomize p-i-t for c
if and only if the vanishing ideal and c
have at least the zero polynomial in
common
uh or kind of broader terms deranization
is uh strictly equivalent to lower
bounds for the vanishing ideal of your
generator
when c is kind of a resource-bounded
computational class
so
our hope with this is that we can focus
research on the generator which we have
a lot of control over
rather than limiting ourselves to
focusing exclusively on syntactic
classes
all the time and because we have control
over the generator that should be
easier and we can make more rapid and
interesting progress
okay so we use this approach of looking
at the vanishing ideal specifically for
the rfe generator
and uh our first result is that the rfe
generator is actually strongly
equivalent to a more well-known
generator the spoke of vogovich
generator
and their equivalent in the sense that
their vanishing ideals are identical up
to rescaling these xi variables
so what this means is that if you have a
class c that's close under variable
rescaling such as just about any
syntactic class that gets looked at
then
one generator works to de-randomize that
class
if and only if the other one does
so that's kind of our first result after
that we take a closer look at the
vanishing ideal itself
and we come up with a generating set for
it so it's a small and explicit set of
polynomials that generate the vanishing
ideal
as an ideal
and the polynomials are explicit in the
sense that they're all kind of simple
structure determinants
a inappropriate subset is what's called
the grounder basis if you know what that
means
but
as implications
we conclude some
bounds on some basic parameters of the
vanishing ideal
namely the minimum degree of any
non-zero polynomial in the vanishing
ideal
the minimum sparsity or number of
monomials
and then if you know what set
multi-linearity means
there's this partition of the variables
and we show that for a certain degree
each part of this partition has to have
at least a certain size
we also use this equivalence between
lower bounds and deranimization
in reverse so because the sv generator
is known to work
for some classes c
the explicit generators that we have in
our generating set
cannot be computed
in such classes c
so there are other explicit polynomials
as well and of course lower bounds
carry over to those polynomials too
so this is one characterization of the
vanishing ideal for rfe and sb
um we also come up with another
characterization
uh in terms of a membership test for the
vanishing ideal
so for multilinear polynomials p
you can express it in terms of partial
derivatives and zero substitutions which
are operations that appear a lot in
literature on sv
and as implications we conclude that
actually these operations are complete
for reasoning with respect to perfect
and sv
if you have a polynomial that's hit by
them then you can prove it using
derivatives and zero substitutions
uh so we demonstrate this kind of
completeness and reasoning
for uh
uh by reproving this result due to
minahama volkovic giving a polynomial
time black box to randomization of
rewards formulas
so their argument has this step that's a
bit uh ad hoc um so in terms of our
membership test we can
replace that stuff by something that's
quite straightforward and simple
uh we also make some new progress on the
randomizing uh read months of olivia
algebraic branching programs um so this
is a frontier class and randomizing pit
and we make a little bit of progress
there
i think that's
uh most of what i have time
to say
so just to recap on the conceptual front
we
showed the utility of doing rational
function substitutions as your generator
and in particular introduced this
generator rv
we took a systematic approach to
de-randomization by looking at the
vanishing ideal
and then uh specifically we showed that
rfp is equivalent to sv in terms of the
vanishing ideals being pretty much the
same
and then we came up with a generating
set for the vanishing ideal and a
membership test and we derived some
consequences of each of these
so i'm a bit
early
so i have one more thing i can say and
i'll ask for questions
um so just to show you what these
generators look like
uh so the rfe generator has this couple
parameters knl
non-negative integers and then there's a
distinct scalar i for each variable x i
called an abscissa
and then
what these generators look like
is first of all you select a certain
number of variables
and then you form a determinant out of
them and this big expression is the
determinant
and you can see that uh kind of two
parts to it on the left you have uh
let's say on the right you have a
vandermonde determinate looking thing um
on the left it's also a vandermonde
determinate looking thing except there's
these xi variables uh introduced
so this is a non-zero polynomial
and
as you vary the choice of variable
you get a generating set for this
vanishing ideal
for rfe and uh
for certain choices of knl this is kind
of
uh equivalently the vanishing ideal for
uh for sv
uh yeah okay so that's what i have time
for so i'll come back to my summary
slide and then ask for questions
thanks andrew uh that does anyone have
any questions
so
can you go back to the slide about the
rfe definition so you you bury
those variables you take
and those are the outputs of your
generator is this right
this these are the generators for the
vanishing idea let me i'll show you what
the definition of rfe is real quick to
have this
as well
yeah so the generator itself
takes in like a rational function and
then the substitution is kind of an
evaluation of that rational function
at this uh point calling up system for
the variable
the previous slide was a definition of
the
generators themselves for the vanishing
ideal for this generator
so
this the seed is the polynomial's g and
h
and
yeah
yeah or you can think of it as being a
single rational function
as its numerator and denominator and
then
and then you plug
you plug
values for
g and h what are those values for g h
any value
uh yeah so they can be any polynomial
with this degree bound um you know the
single variable alpha
and then um substitution that you do for
x i is you evaluate it at a specific
point that's kind of associated to x i
it's kind of a fixed parameter of the
generator
okay thanks
all right thanks andrew
um
yeah gregory are you able to share your
slide for the next talk
right uh let me take care of that
great can everyone see this
yeah yeah it looks great
hello hi everyone um
i'm going to briefly summarize the
talking paper
on uh entitled low bounds for the first
symmetric circuits for the determinant
and this is joint work with anush
so
we're working on a slightly different
model not one of the standard models
that comes up in symmetric in arithmetic
complexity but one that we developed in
a previous paper so why don't i quickly
talk about these things that were that
the paper concerns these things called
symmetric circuits
so we say a circuit is symmetric
normally we specify some group action so
we say we have with respect to
some group action g on the input gates
if every permutation in that group
um on the input gates extends to an
automobile of the circuit right so it
keeps the circuit the same so in other
words we have a circuit something like
this and if we have a permutation that
swaps x and y
then indeed we can see that this
extension automobiles in the circuit
because we can swap those two blue gates
and we can keep the circuit the same
right but indeed if we figure if we
introduce a different permutation say
there's one that source y z we see that
doesn't extend an automotive circuit so
the circuit isn't symmetric with respect
to any group that contains that
transposition
right so these things called symmetric
circuits this is what we uh where we're
very interested in both in this paper
and a previous one and indeed in a
previous paper um we proved upper and
lower bounds uh for symmetric for
symmetric arithmetic circuits um
specifically uh with respect to a
particular group action so the group
action here is the is what we just call
cement symmetric circuits these are
circuits where you simultaneously act on
both the row and columns of some input
matrix of variables and you require this
extends to an automobile circuit
so
these are circuits that in some sense
respect to this action
exponential lower bound with respect to
the permanent
and a polynomial upper bound respect to
the determinant
yeah in this model
now
it's very natural to look at this and go
okay that's that's interesting but why
why do you care about the secular group
action
um and in the permanent case it doesn't
really make a difference
um because if you were to consider a
more natural
group action like the full permutation
group of the permanent well this result
implies that as a special case
um but for the determinate case it
certainly does make a difference and
difference and so we considered other
groups in this paper
and um in particular what we did is we
proved that in fact for the determinant
uh you might want to
um
you know show that this
polynomial upper bound uh sorry uh
polymer upper bound holds even when you
uh consider
uh uh
larger and larger groups but this in
fact isn't the case we proved an
exponential lower bound uh for alt m
cross all 10. so this is where you have
the inputs are
the input to the circuit is a matrix of
variables and you allow the alternating
group to act separately on the rows and
columns of the matrix and you ask
you know what circuits allow these to
extend to automotive automotives of the
circuit
um and indeed we get here an exponential
lower bound so this of course means in
particular you get an exponential lower
bound for the full symmetry group of the
determinants so we sort of answer the
question in this way and we also get a
lower bound for the permanent and what
i'd like to do briefly in this talk
um is talk a little bit about how we get
there and sort of
why this matters
so
um for those of you who've watched the
talk there are sort of two tools um i
speak about in that talk
one is this notion of a support
and this important thing called the
support theorem
and i won't go through this again in too
much detail but essentially what the
support theorem establishes is that if
you have a family of cert of uh
symmetric circuits with respect to some
group in this case alt n cross old n and
they're sub-exponential in size then
you're going to have what are called
you're going to have sublinear size
supports on the circuit
um
and then the second key ingredient um
that we use which again is a
generalization of previous work is this
notion of a bijection game um and for
those of you who come from logic you've
probably seen this before
um for those of you who who are less
familiar with it essentially it's a game
played on two graphs between two players
one of whom is trying to show the graphs
are the same the duplicator and one of
whom's trying to show the difference the
spoiler and they're playing with pebbles
and essentially what's happening is the
duplicator is trying to maintain a
partial isomorphism
between the pebbled positions on the two
graphs and each turn the spoiler can
pick up pebbles and place them on the
graphs
and what we do is
we establish this connection between the
game and supports so in particular we
show that if you have a family of
bipartite graphs and let's suppose that
they they have by partitions one through
n and they have two by their their
bipartitions are labeled one through and
one through n
um
then the duplicator is going to have a
winning strategy in the game
where you have a single bijection
between these two uh between these two
parts and a um
so sorry let me pause from it so the
idea is here we're trying to consider a
generalization of
uh the duplicator is restricted to play
only from a certain number of by a
certain set of digestions
and so we suppose that set of ejections
is generated
um gn
um from
just taking the alt all-time
cross-option alpha
and if the duplicator come in this game
with a linear number of pebbles
uh then in fact any any symmetric any
family symmetric circuits that
distinguishes this pet these pairs of
graphs gn and
alpha gm
must have linear size supports
so that's a bit of a mouthful but let me
just summarize so the idea is
to establish our main results what we
need is a sequence of gra of bipartite
graphs
um which we identify with by jcc
matrices
and a single permutation alpha that
swaps two columns in the by jc matrix so
it swaps two elements in one of the the
um
by partitions and we want to make sure
that duplicator can win this game with a
linear number of pebbles
and
um the by jcc matrices of the graphs gn
and alpha gm have different determinants
but remember alpha gm alpha is just
swapping at columns so
g n and alpha gm
uh are going to have
uh
applying that swap just negates the
determinant so really we just want a
family of graphs
where the determinants are nonzero and
they're duplicating them in these games
right and so that's what pretty much the
work of the paper is all about just
trying to find some way to make sure
that they're duplicating within these
games and that we can uh show the
determinant is non-zero and we use this
thing called the cfi construction
which some of you may have met before
which takes three regular bipartite
graphs and sort of adds these gadgets at
each vertex
and then the sort of crucial thing we go
ahead and prove is that if the
underlying graph gn the one before we've
added all the gadgets has an odd number
of perfect matchings then the by
adjacency matrix of this
cfi graph with all these gadgets has
nonzero determinant right and that
that's what that's sort of the crucial
observation and with that in mind we
then go ahead and actually construct the
sequence of graphs um
just use it you know we need these basic
properties we also require this k well
connectedness property um and this is so
that we can actually play the game
and then lastly we need the determinant
to be non-zero so we require that there
are number of matrix and this is where
the vast majority of the work the paper
comes in and so we prove this by showing
that if you have some random three
regular balance bipartite graph
um we're going to get we're going to
satisfy uh
the first three of these conditions
with high probability
and then we show that you can modify the
graph to satisfy the fourth while
keeping the connectivity high
um and to do this we need all sorts of
facts about the distribution of three
regular balanced bipartite graphs and
and we go into a fair amount of detail
on how to actually construct them but of
course this is not for for a brief talk
here now the important conclusions of
the work now
uh the trouble with with rep
we're talking about something like this
is you have this very specific group all
10 cross alternate floating around now
the important thing is the framework we
introduce this generalization support
generalization of the game the whole
approach we take is largely agnostic to
the group action so really we're trying
to develop a completely general
framework for studying symmetry in this
context now there are some limitations
we can't uh
we can't for example generalize to
support theorem completely which is why
we can't say wonderfully general things
about symmetric circuits
um
but what's interesting about the whole
approach and what we'd like to see
pursued further is this idea that we can
really now open up a spectrum of
symmetry conditions so you can consider
you consider symmetric circuits in
respect to some different group action
um and you can kind of
interpolate between very symmetric
circuits on the one hand and sort of
ordinary arithmetic circuits on the
other which are just symmetric respect
the trivial group
and uh why don't i pause there
and and take any questions
yeah thanks gregory um yeah does anyone
have any questions
can you maybe say a few words about the
construction
uh
the
yeah the fraction of these graphs
yeah
sure
so um
so uh are you familiar with this uh
sciatica construction already or not so
much
okay right so essentially you just you
start off with the three regular
bipartite graph right and i've almost
kind of pictured it over here so you
take every um
every vertex and for each edge coming
into the graph you sort of you take that
edge and split it into two
so you can see
over here what i mean by splitting into
two right so so the edge for example f
becomes f0 and f1
um and then the idea is you have these
internal vertices one for each even
subset of the um
of the adjacent of the incident edges
and and f0 is adjacent to each
uh
into each one of those internal vertices
in which f is not and f1 is adjacent to
each one of those internal vertices in
which f is
right so you can see f1 is adjacent to
vfg
right and this is how you build up these
the families of cypher immunographs are
normally
if you do see these elsewhere you'll see
that people add a twist into them and
then they study them in our case we just
we're just interested in one of these
graphs
um
maybe so i just described the
construction
perhaps as a specific question
so it's important for you to maintain
true regularity for ease of analysis or
maybe
four regular graphs would also be
interesting here
for your argument so
you certainly can do cypher m1
constructions with uh
different size graphs in this case
we would not if you were to do this with
four regular graphs i think you would
firstly not have the balance required
when you when you consider these as
bipartite graphs
um
which is what we need and
the analysis would certainly be very
different because a lot of the work here
is actually counting the number of
perfect matchings in these graphs and
showing this connection between the
perfect matchings the other line graphs
and the uh and the determinant
okay thanks
thanks gregory yeah thanks for the nice
um
touchant are you able to share your
screen now
sure
um
really you have to unshare subject okay
yeah it looks great
all right uh
thank you everyone um for coming thank
you josh for the introductions
um
i'm graduate at university of chicago
i'll be talking about stid and
non-competitive ranks of matrixly
algebras
this joint work with gabo divanyosh and
you mean
so
so
again another one-sided summary
so what we do is we discover a new
family of pid instances
using structured vector spaces or in
other words the algebras and we solve
them that is we do randomize pid for
that class so this is an illustration of
what the algebra is
and the key message is that adding
structure
can make life easier
which is not something alien to this
audience
okay
so
again the polynomial identity testing
problem is one in which you have a
polynomial p
and you want to check whether it's
identically zero or not
so in the black box setting you just
query it at points and you get its
evaluation in the white box setting you
have access to a circuit computing
and
you want to de-randomize the natural
randomized algorithm
and
the special case that we are looking at
is that of symbolic determinant identity
testing
so this is a special case of pid in
which your polynomial has this specific
form so it's the determinant of a
symbolic matrix
which can be written in the following
form so it's some summation x i a i
where x i are your n determinants and a
i's are n cross and matrices over some
base field f
right and you want to do p id for this
in the white box setting we will assume
that we have access to the ai's
rather than just this oracle
and while this might seem like a very
special case
this is still quite general so
carbonates and impartials have showed
that if you manage to put this in n sub
x so not even asking for polynomial time
algorithms but if you just show that
there are some non-trivial certificates
uh that is which can witnesses for the
singularity of these determinants then
you get very strong lower bounds
so
this case is quite interesting from that
perspective and from uh my point of view
it's nice because we can apply linear
algebra here right it's very cleaner at
the right setup
so
from this viewpoint we now assume that
we have access to these ai's and we
denote by calligraphic a the linear span
of these airs so this is a linear space
which is a subspace of the n square
dimensional space of all matrices over f
and we say that the space is singular if
every matrix in this space is in there
so this is just a change of words
because it's exactly equivalent to
saying that the symbolic determinant
vanishes because this is just a generic
element in your linear span
right
all right so so the goal is to identify
whether a matrix space is singular or
not
and there have been two kinds of
certificates that have been
studied uh
mostly in the literature
the first is what's called a strong
subspace
so let u be a subspace of fm
we think of these ais as maps between fn
to f n because recall that these are n
by n matrices
so we can look at
uh the image of this so we take the
image under each ai and we take the
linear span of that
and the space is called shrunk subspace
if the dimension strictly falls
right
so this certifies that your space is
singular because if you had a
non-singular matrix here the image of u
under just that one matrix would have
dimension equal to u
so this could not be true right
so this is a certificate uh a proof of
the fact that yours your space is
singular and if i give you such a chunks
of space you can verify this in
polynomially many operations
right the hard task of course is to find
such a substance
the other kind of certificate is what's
called a linear kernel
so a bunch of vectors is a linear kernel
for your matrix space if the following
holds identically
and this has a very easy interpretation
so for any x
so let's fix an x so this represents a
matrix in your space it's a linear
combination and this is a kernel vector
for the set matrix
right
so this is essentially saying that there
is a uniform way of generating kernels
for each of your matrix and since you
have at least one vector in the content
then you have uh
that the matrix is singular
and this certificate is in fact easier
in a way than subspaces because you can
just set up a system of equation in n
times and variables and
using this condition you you can compute
whether there is such a vector in
polynomial time
so now let's look at uh
the entire landscape of singular matrix
spaces
so you have some subspaces some matrix
spaces that do possess this certificate
the chunks of space certificate so one
special family uh is when each of your
matrices rank one uh this comes about
from the material intersection problem
now this case was recently solved
as in uh we now know deterministic
algorithms to test whether there is a
strong subspace given as input a matrix
space so this was work due to gargoyles
oliver and victorson using analytic
methods on matrix and operator scaling
and
this works over every field of category
uh zero
whereas uh ivanhoe and subramaniam gave
a very different algebraic algorithm
that works over every field regardless
of the characteristic
now on the other hand you have spaces
which admit these linear kernels so
one classic example is that of metroid
parity or graph rigidity uh where each
ai has rank 2.
and as we have seen this is
just from the perspective of sdit it's
kind of tricky you set up a linear
system and you can check this
right
but clearly this is not exhaust
everything right as the problem would be
solved
so
for example the space of skew symmetric
matrices of what size
is singular but it does not possess
either of these certificates
similarly
there are some more
uh isolated examples uh that can be
found in the literature and the key
question now is uh what else do we have
right so what what are the other cases
of the sdid problem uh
that are still unsolved that is that
that do not possess each of these
certificates and how can we solve this
idea
so this is the goal
and uh
i'll just introduce quickly what a
matrixy algebraic so matrix lee algebra
is nothing but a matrix space as before
which is closed also under the
commutator bracket
right
so
the space of all matrices is closed but
the space of all trace this matrices is
also close under this so it's a matrices
and so is the space of all skew
symmetric matrices right so if is this a
matrix space is just a vector space with
this additional structure
all right
so now i just mention our results
uh informally and slightly incorrectly
uh but look at the full talk for the
precise statements so what we show is
that if you have any non-trivial matrix
the algebra over the complex numbers
then it does not admit either of these
certificates
so in other words it gives rise to a new
family of examples
so if your matrix the algebra is
singular then it definitely does not for
this either of these certificates
removing certain trivial cases when it
definitely does
so this in fact enlarges the family of
skew symmetric matrices which we just
saw is earlier
right so this is generalizing that
family of results
so this is like the key uh structural
result and then we show that uh indeed
we can solve
the polynomial
identity testing or the stit problem for
this that is we can de-randomize
the natural testing algorithm
right so these are the main results
and thank you thank you for listening
open questions
thanks to sean um yeah does anybody have
any questions
uh i have a question actually
i'm i'm wondering if uh
like which which of the two results you
just mentioned was was more surprising
to you i guess like that
that it it does does not give rise to
singular matrix spaces or that it does
have an efficient algorithm anyway
uh
so the
i mean i definitely say that it does not
possess uh chunks of spaces
was more uh
surprising like initially i did not like
i expected this to hold for like some
special types of li algebras
but not for like every
uh this thing so like we started out
with like a case case analysis based on
like some special families of the
algebras and then it seemed like it
might not hold in general but then yeah
so i guess that was definitely more
surprising the the algorithm actually is
uh you uses like uh very classical facts
about the algebras
so it reduces the problem to a sub
algebra called the cartesian algebra
and
stit for cartons of algebra
so
i guess yeah this is like the more
surprising part of it
thanks
um it looks like there's a question in
chat also ilya volkovic asks
um
do you get any new lower bounds from
these pip algorithms
uh i do not uh
i do not suspect so because
uh
we are like the algorithm itself is
reducing it to like a very uh like a
depth 2 case so essentially the
algorithm involves finding like a sub
algebra instead your algebra
inside the entire space uh for which pid
reduces to like a depth to a case like
which is like very easy so i don't
expect uh this to give new lower bounds
um
but i haven't thought in this direction
maybe so this goggles on the call like
if he has
insights on this but i don't think so
that this would be into you know lower
bounds
because it's not like we're solving a
new family of pit uh in the sense of
like a structural family or something
it's more like uh
we're reducing it to a known family of
case for which we know how to software
got it thanks so much to sean thanks for
the nice talk
um
okay um
gaurav are you able to share your slides
now
yes uh just one second
can you see my slides
um yeah yeah it looks great
okay good awesome
yeah thanks josh uh
so i'm gaurav i'll be talking about uh
efficient reconstruction of depth 3
circuits with top 5 into
so i don't need to define arithmetic
circuits for this audience the only
thing sort of to take away from this
slide is that we'll only be
concerned with finite fields
the reconstruction problem is as follows
so let delta be a class of arithmetic
circuits we want to find an algorithm
which takes as input a black box access
to some circuit
which computes polynomial on n variables
in degree d
it outputs another circuit from the same
class
it also computes the same polynomial or
it cannot reconstruct
the size of the output we want it to be
polynomial in n d and
the log of the field size
and the other requirements are the
reconstruction should be
correct with high probability whenever
the circuit is
coming from delta
we would want this algorithm to run in
time polynomial in nd log f uh
and this is important because this is
sort of the main thing that we are
trying to address in this work uh the
dependency on the on the
log of the field size
okay so uh the
circuit class of interest here is uh
homogeneous step three arithmetic
circuits uh these are
layered circuits with alternating
addition and multiplication gates and
homogeneity for reconstruction problems
is sort of without loss of generality
uh
homogeneous circuits are just circuits
where like every
every node in the circuit computes a
homogeneous polynomial so
the the leaf nodes will be variables and
the multiplication nodes will have the
same degree and so on
now
why are the three circuits important i
think most people in the audience know
this i'll just write a
few things here
so
efficient black box pit is known uh for
bounded uh fannin
uh death reduction results are there
non-trivial lower bounds are known for
certain polynomials and there are many
other reasons
now i'll talk about some previous work
on reconstruction of depth three
circuits i'll just focus on a few other
works which are more relevant for this
this uh paper uh so for k equal to one
basically so k was the top finding of
the circuit so k equal to one just
becomes a product of linear forms and
you can just factorize using
uh an algorithm from carlton integer
which
will give you the reconstruction for
k equal to 2 becomes more interesting
and
more non-trivial
so spirica gave a randomized algorithm
which ran in time uh
which runs in time uh quasi polynomial
and dnf
uh and then this was generalized by
carnegie
for k greater than two but not exactly
for f3 circuits but something called
generalized f3 circuits
the time complexity still remained
costly polynomial india
and there are many other works on
reconstruction of three circuits and
sort of other other
[Music]
circuits and over
characteristic zero fields or average
case and so on which i will not discuss
more uh to stick to the main result
uh okay so the two main questions sort
of which we try to address is uh can we
design a reconstruction algorithm for
depth three circuits that runs in time
polynomial in log of mod f and as we saw
from the two prior works on by spinker
and karen spinker it was quasi
polynomial in dnf
so specifically for k equal to 2 this
was asked as an open problem
and the second question is can we make
this algorithm fully polynomial time
basically like
not just polynomial log of modic but
also in lnd
okay to to state my these are the
questions that we're going to address in
this work uh to state the main results i
need to define something called the rank
of the circuit so
uh so as you can see like any any uh
sigma pi sigma 2
so 2 is so the this first parameter is
the is the fan of that operation gate
uh so any such circuit will compute a
polynomial which is sum of two product
of linear forms
if we just pull out all the common
factors common linear forms from here as
the gcd then we are left with this and
the rank is now defined as the span of
the dimension of the span of whatever is
left inside the bracket after you pull
things out so these are sort of the
essential number of variables that are
there in once you have pulled off the
gcd
and
yeah and the rank of the for polynomial
is the smallest rank of any sigma by
sigma two circuit that computes it
so this rank is an important concept
because uh results sort of split into
two parts on the basis of this
so these are the two main results so we
have a low ranking construction result
and a high rank reconstruction result in
the
the main thing to sort of notice that in
both the results the dependencies in the
field size is
uh polynomial of mod f
uh the lowering cases that the rank is
actually uh bounded by log qp
and
in this case we don't output like the
sigma by sigma 2 circuit but a sigma by
sigma k circuit with k much larger
but we run in time
end it the log qp times log of mod after
the one and in high rank reconstruction
this is sort of the more interesting
case
where we
assume that rank is uh omega log cube d
in this case our algorithm is actually
completely foreign time in all the three
parameters and we output a sigma by
sigma two circuit so it's a proper
reconstruction algorithm
uh
okay there are some remarks which i will
sort of skip because i want to give a
few
uh give some idea about uh the algorithm
okay
so
to understand the algorithm we first
need to understand sort of this this is
the main one of the main pieces of spill
cars reconstruction algorithm
so
again recall f is a 1 to a d plus b 1 to
b d
and suppose we have access to a linearly
independent set a 1 to a t with t large
enough so omega log d
then we can reconstruct this second
polynomial
and once you have done that you can
actually subtract it from f factorize
the black box again and get a1280 also
so
uh yeah so so so because construction
relies on like having access to an
allies set
uh a1 to 80 which is large enough and
the the sort of the rest of the steps
follow like this suppose like a1 to 80
were just the variables x1 to xt
without loss of generality then
they just go
like restrict the polynomial to x 1
equal to 0 x 2 equal to 0 x i equal to 0
x equal to 0 and so on
and once you restrict it like you get a
product of linear forms and you can
factorize the block box to get like some
so restrictions of b 1 into b 1 to b d
to x 1 equal to 0 x 2 equal to 0 and so
on and basically what they say is that
you can glue two of these together to
get back b1 to b
and either like yeah so one of these
will work either you will be able to do
restriction of x one two restriction
with x two or with some other x i you
will be able to glue and you will be
able to get the product
so basically like the the main thing is
getting this li set
uh now what they do is they actually
perform some kind of a good first search
over linear forms in a high dimensional
space which leads to the bad time
complexity we make this process
efficient using some structural results
about uh polynomials uh
the polynomial that we have at hand
so to give the first structural result
let me just define a few notations so f
is again the same thing linear line of f
is the product of all linear factors of
f
and long line of f is just f by linear
so all the non-linear product of
non-linear individuals sort of say
and
so we define this s of knowledge in f as
the set of all four dimension two
subspaces
on which f vanishes so why is this an
interesting thing to study because uh we
are trying to recover these ais and bis
and uh you can see that f restricted to
a i
equal to zero and b j equal to zero will
be zero so f vanishes on
the the co dimension two space where a i
and b j are zero that's why like this
this set is interesting to us and what
we show first in the first structural
result is that uh this set is actually
small
and there's a randomized algorithm which
can recover this polynomial time
so
that's the first structural result i
will not go into the proof of this
but i will try to show how i can use
this to uh to solve the problem so for
this talk i'm going to make further
assumptions in the polynomial to like
keep things simple so i'm going to
assume that gcd of ai and bj is one so
basically nothing is going to come out
common
i'm also gonna because so i'm only
trying to prove theorem two right now
the higher rank okay so i'll further
assume that both the two gates actually
have like high rank
uh not just the union number two and the
third thing i'm going to assume the last
thing i'm going to assume is that
there's no linear factor for this
polynomial note that
the first thing first assumption doesn't
imply this like because here's a
polynomial where a ibj's are co-prime
and
still factorizes the product
so
oh okay i just want to mention you have
about 30 seconds left for yourself sorry
sorry okay so then i'll i'll just skip
to okay i think i timed myself really
badly okay so basically like these uh
wij
the space
ai equal to zero pj equal to zero and
this is sort of constructed using this
first structural result
and uh uh
we can use this wijs to get back the ai
majors so we can use w i j and w i k
actually they will both have ai in
common so we'll be able to construct
this set and now from this set
notice that like these have both these
are linear forms from both gates and
splash construction only requires linear
forms from one of the gates so to
further uh
sort of uh get to that one part we have
a second structural result which
basically
is about ordinary lines
in a space in a high dimensional space
so suppose let me just tell you what an
ordinary line is so it's if this is a
set of points and already line is a line
which contains exactly two points and
the structural result second structural
result is that
if you have a set s and a set t which is
high dimensional
then there is always a small tnt such
that the union of the ordinary lines of
the high dimension is is high
dimensional so
previously the results like this were
one for the number of ordinary lines
through a point but this one is for the
union of the
dimensions so let's say this is t this
is s then these are all there's a t and
t such that all these lines and high
dimensional space and we use this to
actually go from this l a 1 to a b 1 to
b d all the way down to like just one
uh
yeah the set with just all the ai's all
the bj's and then we are back to spin
social structure yeah so
apologies for not being able to cover
this uh because of time constraints
and yeah this is future work i'd like to
stop here thank you
thanks so much gaurav
yeah okay i think in the interest of
time let's hold questions for now and
move on to the last talk but please feel
free to ask star of questions like in
the zoom chat for example
okay
uh yeah thanks so much for the nice talk
and then uh
are you here or
oh yeah can you share your slides for
the last for your presentation
uh it looks great but you're muted in
zoom right now so we can't hear you
uh
yeah
oh perfect yeah i can hear you and see
the slides now okay
so the plan of our talk is following
first i will talk about the basic
computation model next i will talk about
the problems that we address in our work
which will be followed by the results
and in time permits we try to keep the
ideas and i will conclude my talk with
some open problems
so the basic computational model here is
arithmetic circuit which is a natural
model for computing polynomials here
variables are labeled at the bottom and
these are composed by addition and
multiplication gates finally a
polynomial is computed at the top gate
the size of the circuit is the number of
nodes appearing in it and in our
research for this one we are interested
with molecular circuits and modern
polynomials so a polynomial is called
monotone if every coefficient in it is
non-negative
and a circuit is called monotone if the
edge labeling
is non-negative
so naturally our motion circuit computes
a modern polynomial as shown in this
example
so there are lots of interesting
polynomials which are monotone and let
me give you some examples the first one
is the elementary symmetric polynomial
which is of
k and on n variables
and the second one is the well known
permanent polynomial corresponding to a
matrix of variables of dimension in
percent
now lots of interesting lower bounds
were already known against monotone
computation but lots of problems were
open also
so we here address two such open
problems the first one is
to understand what is the strongest
possible lower bond we can expect
against monotone computation
so we want a molten polynomial on n
variable which shows movement circuit
lower bound of 2 to the power omega n
this equals strongly exponential
now observe our known heart polynomial
permanent is not a candidate for this
lower part because the permanent
polynomial is on n squared variable and
the number of monomial is like 2 to the
power order n
so any depth to circuit will be of size
to trigger order n log n if it computes
a permanent polynomial
now from 80s people had showed strongly
exponential lower bound against modern
computation
but all those polynomials where in vnp
which is an algebraic analog of the
class np defined by valid so what about
the class tp which is an algebraic
analog of the class p turns out that
valiant in 1979 german state in 1982
gave us polynomial families in pp which
exhibits exponential size into lower
point
so in this work we address this question
can we have
strongly exponential lower bound for a
few polynomials
for the second problem our motivation is
that we have good monotone lower bounds
but can those monotone lower bounds give
you general circuit number
well ruby showed us an approach in 2020
and that can be interpreted following
this problem
so is there a hard polynomial if such
that for every non-negative epsilon this
polynomial of the form e plus epsilon
times f which you call as c epsilon has
large modern complexity
well this polynomial e is a monotone
polynomial which has a very efficient
motion circuit
so what we showed
imply the following
that
if our polynomial a is on degree d and
on n variable then by choosing the easy
polynomial as one plus summation x i
whole to the power d if we show monotone
lower bound on g epsilon for sufficient
is small non-negative epsilon
then we will get general circuit lower
bound on the polynomial f
and interestingly if we want general set
multi-linear circuit lower bound against
our polynomial if
then we can choose our easy polynomial
as this full set multi-linear polynomial
now
some important point about this approach
or following observe but epsilon equal
to 0 this g 0 polynomial has very
efficient modern circuit because that is
the easy polynomial
so
the polynomial f should be hard enough
such that the monotone lower bound of
this g epsilon polynomial
displays significant
discontinuity when epsilon approaches to
zero
and the second important point here that
observed if you choose easy polynomial
as this polynomial one plus function x
equal to the power d then observe this g
x seven polynomial has full monomial
support that is every possible
polynomial of degree d is appearing in
this g epsilon polynomial
similarly if we choose our easy
polynomial as this full set multi-linear
polynomial then
every possible set multi-linear
polynomial is appearing in this c
epsilon polynomial
so
when if we want to show more to lower
bound which is g epsilon polynomial
support based techniques which have been
mostly devised to do more lower bound
simply fails here
and the technique that works here should
somehow
crucially use the coefficients of the
monomial in this g epsilon polynomial
now
the this hardness of this approach will
first overcome by cdn in their stock
2021 paper
and they showed the first exponential
size epsilon sensitive monotone lower
bound against a polynomial family in vnp
with the condition that epsilon at least
2 to the power minus omega root n
and in this work we ask can we show this
for vp polynomial
now
both of our result draws intuitions and
techniques from communication complexity
and interestingly in both our case
target polynomial is this spanning tree
polynomial it's a well-known polynomial
so let me define it
so intuitively the spanning tree
polynomial consists of monomial which
has
ah which are representing spanning tree
in a graph
but
we are interested in a special kind of
spanish
so consider this three vertex graph and
this is a spanning tree polynomial
corresponding to this graph here every
monomial is representing the spanning
tree which is rooted at 1 such as this
monomial x 2 1 times 6 c 1 is
representing 2 goes to 1 and 3 goes to
1.
so only those spanning trees which are
rooted at the vertex one are in my
monomials
now
more formally we always consider our
graph as bidirective that is whenever we
want to give an edge between two
vertices we gave two edges one in each
direction
now sir every monomial here will give
you a map h map from the vertices
such as that this monomial x 2 1 times 6
3 1 will give you the map 2 goes to 1
and 3 goes to 1
so this t set consists all such maps
which gives you
spanning tree rooted vertex 1 in your
graph g
and formally the spanning tree
polynomial consists of all such
millennials
now the upper bound for this polynomial
was shown long before and it can be
computed by a determinant computation
using
to theory
now let's see our results
the first
result addressing the first problem
and we show that the spanning tree
polynomials defined for a family of
constant degree expander graphs or n
vertices required motor circuit of size
2 to the power omega n
and for the second problem we show the
family of spanning tree polynomials for
complete graph on n vertices required
exponential size epsilon sensitive
monotone lower bound in the set
multimeter setting for epsilon at least
two to the power minus omega beta
now both this works at a generalization
of the work
done by chairman street in his monotone
lower bound basement means exponential
size monotonous bond
the first one is a quantitative
improvement quality quantitative
improvement because ah german seed also
used the spanish polynomial
and this is a sharp door bomb and the
second one can be thought of as a
qualitative improvement
how much time i have
uh just about 30 seconds left
i would like to give some intuition how
the communication complexity is coming
to the picture but unfortunately i don't
think we can have so let me go to the
open problem section
we have interesting open problems in our
research i am giving you two such
problem the first one is can we have an
explicit family of polynomials which has
and
sm which has small monotone formula a
small arithmetic formulas but the
monotone circuit complexity is still
strongly exponential because the reason
for this question is our spanning two
polynomial is known to have a very
efficient non-monotone avp but we do not
know
about the case of formula
and our second
problem is can we can you have a
strongly exponential size epsilon
sensitive lower bond because our epsilon
sensitive lower bound is exponential not
strongly exponential since the number of
variables is inspect
so
for
more explanation about our work please
do check the youtube video invite you to
check our paper also thank you for
watching
thanks so much um
maybe are there any like very quick
questions yeah we're just about out of
time for the session
um okay maybe in the interest of time
let's also let's also skip questions for
now but um i'm sure you can find utsab
and all the speakers uh afterwards by
email or in the in the gather town
um so thank you again to all the
speakers for the session for the really
nice talks and i think the the next itcs
session is starting about now in the
other
zoom room so thanks everybody
you